All right, let's jump right in.
A lot of today's show is going to be essentially
getting ourselves caught up and framed in
terms of the state of the Republican Party
right now.
And while some of you may think this has everything
to do with Trump, it doesn't.
It has some to do with Trump and it has a
lot to do with some of the developing factions
in the Republican Party, but also just the
fundamental kind of empirical problems that
need to be solved before, if and before the
Republican Party would be able to participate
in any meaningful political policy and scientific
discussion.
And this may be sort of not clear in what
I'm talking about.
But to begin with, let's start with part of
the problem with scientific framing in the
Republican Party.
We have a new poll out now from economist
YouGov which shows that Republicans trust
on medical issues, Donald Trump over, Dr.
Anthony Fauci over the CDC and maybe not surprisingly,
over the Biden administration.
That one maybe would be to be expected.
But less indicative of a problem, then, is
the lack of trust in Dr. Fauci and the CDC.
The vast majority of Republicans surveyed
say they trust Donald Trump on medical advice,
despite the fact that he wondered about injecting
bleach, disinfectants, etc..
66 percent of self-identified Republicans
say they trust Trump a lot or somewhat for
medical advice.
Only 11 percent of Republicans trust Joe Biden.
Now, that's less of an obvious problem to
me in the sense that they're both politicians.
Now, of course, you and I would look at that
and say, well, but Joe Biden's positions are
just repeating what doctors say, whereas Trump's
have been arguing against doctors, no doubt
about it.
But it's less concerning then when you compare
to Dr. Fauci and the CDC, you look at 20,
the CDC had the highest level of trust, that
57 percent overall.
Dr. Anthony Fauci had 48 percent trust overall.
But when you look specifically at Republicans,
Republicans trust Trump more than 40 and also
more than the CDC.
So why do I care about this?
It's not because I want to go and make fun
of Trump who trust Trump over Dr. Fauci.
I really don't care.
Many of them believe lots of things that aren't
true.
And it doesn't really matter in terms of the
political discourse or in making specific
things happen.
They just have different beliefs and we just
sort of write it off here.
It has a very practical life and death implication.
When you think back to the start of the pandemic
and you look at the disastrous U.S. response,
much of what we see today is as a result of
that, when Donald Trump and Republicans I
don't know if pretended or lied or whatever,
didn't know all along how serious this was
and the mask discussion where they were against
masks and the guidelines discussion where
they were against guidelines, they open everything
people.
And then, of course, as we got into the vaccine
era, if for a year you've been told this isn't
really serious and you don't need to do anything,
of course you're going to be less likely to
want a vaccine.
Why would you need a vaccine for something
you've been told for a year isn't serious
anyway.
And then the conspiracy's and then the Bill
Gates RFID chip vaccinations or whatever the
case may be.
This has very real world implications.
And when you now look at the numbers and you
look at I mean, could there be more dramatically
different vaccine situations than, for example,
Mississippi and Massachusetts to pick two
states that start with the letter M widely
reporting in Mississippi, tens of thousands
of vaccination appointments that no one's
showing up to.
They are trying to figure out in Mississippi,
what do we do?
Because we have all these locations, we have
all these appointments available.
We have all this vaccine, and people aren't
signing up compared to a state like Massachusetts
where 92 percent of the population says that
they want the vaccine.
Massachusetts reportedly 30 days away from
herd immunity.
Very different situation in Mississippi while
it's warm or warming, while we are seeing
a decline of cases.
OK, maybe you're not going to see dramatically
different situations when if indeed this becomes
seasonal and we start to see another uptick
in the fall, you are going to see another
two tiered system from states with herd immunity
and states that completely lack it.
So when when you see a poll and it says these
Republicans trust Trump more than Fouchier,
the CDC, it is easy to just laugh it off and
say, look at these stupid people.
But it affects everybody as we know, not everybody
can.
Get vaccinated, children won't be able to
get vaccinated for some time, we still don't
know how long, hopefully 12 to 16 and 12 to
18 very soon, you know, eight to 12 is going
to take longer, etc.
This has a real world impact.
And when you when you trust Trump over Foushee,
it follows perfectly logically that Republicans
would be Trump supporting Republicans would
be the most anti vaccine group in the United
States at this point in time.
How do you change this?
I don't know.
We have seen the antiwar sentiment decline.
The number of people who want the vaccine
has gone up.
One idea from from a couple of weeks ago was
maybe if there are more pastors and clergy
that are saying get the vaccine as a religious
duty, the vaccine.
But a judge saying over the weekend, God allowed
the vaccine.
The vaccine exists in the context of God imagined
God.
You know, if if he was really got bad, God
would have prevented it or something like
that makes no sense to me based on my sensibilities.
Maybe that would work in at least getting
more religious Republicans to be interested
in the vaccine.
I don't know what the answer is, but the point
is this has real world impact.
We talk sometimes about flat earth as a relatively
benign conspiracy theory.
You can make the case with flat earth that
often flat earth or believe lots of other
stuff that is damaging.
You've got a lot of overlap between flat earth
and other types of conspiracy theories and
anti-Semitic conspiracy theorists.
You know, one world government type stuff
by itself, flat earth as a belief is not damaging
in the same way that the false beliefs about
the pandemic are.
And we're seeing that translate in very real
terms.
These people trust Trump over Foushee and
they are one of the most anti vaccine groups.
How do we fix it?
I don't know what I do know.
Big picture is that placating the anti VAX
beliefs is not the way forward.
And speaking of placating and negotiating
with terrorists, we have to talk next about
Joe Manchin